i am mark monster and we have with us here creepy the clown hey yeah tell them where it's at creepy the clown yeah well here in America it's gonna take ten presidents to fix the problems here yes indeed ladies and gentlemen don't let the illusion fool you work the Trump rally and believe it or not delusions are greater than great the spectacle is even greater not since Barnum & Bailey has the sideshow been so spectacular as I would say hurry hurry step right up and see the sideshow it's gonna take a miracle to save them yes indeed so all of you out there in Great Britain all of you in the British Isles mark monster wants to wish you all a very happy healthy prosperous year